Welcome, everybody, to the next installment of Chemistry to the Clinic.
This is part two of four, Beyond Inhibition: The Next
Frontier in Proximity Inducing Therapies.
I'm Michael Erb. I'm a chemical biologist in the Department of Chemistry at the
Scripps Research Institute,
and I'm incredibly excited to host this
very special session. As many of you know,
the Chemistry to the Clinic sessions are put on each year by the Chemistry and
Cancer Research
working group,
giving us a dedicated platform for chemists and biologists, physicians, data
scientists across academia and industry to come together
with the focus of therapeutic innovation, talking about
the chemistry of new medicines.
Proximity pharmacology unlocks two quite monumental
advances in chemical biology and therapeutic science, the ability to address
targets that are conventionally unligandable and the ability
to rewire the endogenous machinery of cancer cells to act
on some therapeutic target or pathway or process, turning the cell
against itself. We'll hear much more about this
from our speakers today, William Gibson from the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute and
Steven Banic from Stanford University.
And I will get us started with a new story emerging from
my laboratory in which we discovered a novel class of
heterobifunctional small molecules that can
rewire DNA repair processes.
One moment, please.
None of this seems to be working.
Okay, he's coming up to help you.
Do I need to use the laptop?
Oh, thanks.
Now nothing seems to advance here.
Okay, we'll use this.
Fantastic. Thank you everyone for your patience. Sorry about that.
So my laboratory is principally interested in understanding
gene regulatory control, or at least this is what we got focused on when we started
the lab. We want to use small molecule tools as biological
reagents to understand the
mechanistic underpinnings of transcriptional control in tumor agenesis and
identify targets and pathways that we can intercept with small molecules.
But more and more recently, we have
picked up quite a focus on induced proximity, proximity
pharmacology as a way to access new targets in transcriptional regulatory control
that we haven't previously been able to address.
And we've embarked on some new territory that I'll share
with you today.
These are small molecules that bind simultaneously to PARP
enzymes and the BET family of transcriptional co-regulators and have
some quite unanticipated effects in the processes of
DNA damage repair, and I'll go into some of that today.
There are many more questions, I think it's fair to say, than answers, but
this is quite an exciting new area of research for us, and I think
that it might be of interest to many that are in this field.
If you'll indulge me just for one quick moment, I'll explain how we got in this
area of DNA damage repair from transcriptional regulatory
control. And it really stems from our collaborative
work with Ben Cravatt's group. Through his
pioneering platforms in activity-based protein profiling, we were
lucky to collaborate with them on a discovery of a small molecule that
binds to a cysteine within the DNA
binding domain of the pioneer and proto-oncogenic transcription factor,
FOXA1.
This small molecule had quite unanticipated activity in living
cells, in prostate cancer cells, that changes the motifs that are recognized by
FOXA1, creating thousands of new binding sites for this
oncogenic transcription factor on the genome.
And it does that by stabilizing small
interactions between FOXA1 and what are
weak DNA binding motifs. The
sequences that it alters the specificity for
are in direct proximity to where this cysteine is located in three-dimensional
space, and we think that there might be some interaction
between the small molecule and the nucleic acids in that region
altering the
binary complex of FOXA1 on DNA. One
thought, and we don't have a structure yet to know exactly how the molecular
recognition occurs here, but one thought is that the small molecule might actually
insert into DNA at a composite pocket and
interface formed between that loop where cysteine 258 resides and the minor
groove of DNA,
and maybe that's responsible for the changes in sequence
specificity that occur in that region.
And there's some precedent for this in the literature.
There are these beautiful molecules from GSK that insert
into DNA and inhibit DNA methyltransferases by
binding exclusively to this composite pocket formed between protein and nucleic
acids. And we've known for many years now gyrase inhibitors
that do a similar thing in a more bifunctional way, inserting
into DNA, intercalating into DNA, but simultaneously
engaging topoisomerase. And the interesting fact of these small
molecules is that although they intercalate in the context of the protein that's
present, they can't intercalate into DNA on their own.
So there's this context dependent ability to bind DNA that's probably
seeded by some very weak affinity for
DNAAnd so we've been wondering if this is maybe a generalizable approach
for going after transcription factors.
Maybe the learnings from FOXA1 could be generalized to other classes of
high-value therapeutic targets in the transcription factor space.
But first, we wanted to understand the principles of what you could do with small
molecules that trap proteins onto DNA.
And so we've been exploring this in a more modular and
heterobifunctional way as we try to
continue our exploration of this space.
To do this, we designed heterobifunctional small molecules that
leverage the trapping capacity of conventional PARP inhibitors.
PARP is a DNA repair enzyme that recognizes single-stranded DNA breaks,
and PARP inhibitors are very well known to elicit synthetic lethality
with homologous recombination deficiencies by virtue of this
trapping activity of PARP inhibitors.
So when PARP is inhibited on DNA, it becomes
immobilized onto those sites of DNA damage, and that
creates a toxic species to the cell that is more detrimental
to cell viability than is PARP loss of
function. In fact,
we know from genetic studies that if you knock out PARP1,
tumors become quite resistant to the effects of PARP inhibition,
highlighting this gain-of-function toxicity of PARP inhibition, and that
stems from this trapping capacity.
So we wondered if this would give us a very nice modular
handle in which we could design then heterobifunctional molecules
that use PARP trapping as an
anchor to bring other proteins ectopically to sites of DNA
damage, and what might we learn from that experience.
This is work led by
three really talented members in the group, a post-doc, Bryce de Camara,
Eric Belota, who will be defending his thesis soon, and Aaron Broderick, who's
just a couple years more junior.
In getting started on this idea, we decided to utilize
BET bromodomain inhibitors for the exogenous recruitment of other proteins to
DNA damage, and that was a somewhat marriage of convenience.
The chemistry is quite easy there, but also PARP and BET bromodomain proteins
are in many of the same places at the same time, involved in transcriptional
regulation and also DNA repair. And we thought they might have a great number of
opportunities to interfere with each other's function or create some sort of
gain-of-function effect in the cell.
And to understand that these molecules were doing anything, we first asked
the question of whether they are engaging their targets and whether we
see effects in the cells. This is a BRD4 target
engagement assay, where you can see JQ1, the prototypical BET
bromodomain inhibitor, having very nice engagement of BRD4.
And our PSIP molecules showed a little bit of BET bromodomain engagement, but it
was quite severely reduced. And I'll bring your attention to this compound
2, PSIP1,
where we saw severely diminished BET bromodomain
engagement.
And the story was similar for PARP.
So we see almost undetectable PARP1 engagement in these cells with
the small molecule PSIP1. And despite those weak
binary engagement
profiles,
PSIP1 had this
cytotoxicity that was equivalent to BET bromodomain inhibition,
more severe than PARP inhibition.
And so this brought up one of two possibilities in our mind.
Perhaps we had picked up some unfortunate off-target effect,
just inhibiting polo kinase or something unanticipated, or they might be
functioning through proximity pharmacology.
Even though we have very weak equilibrium engagement of
both ends of the target, that doesn't exclude the possibility that we're creating
a low stoichiometry ternary complex that has some
durable biological effect through
some kind of irreversible event.
And I hope I'll convince you that it's the second option.
This is an assay where we looked at whether these molecules
preserved synthetic lethality with HR deficiencies, a DLD1 BRCA2
isogenic knockout model. And we can see that like rucaparib, PSIP1
has a major shift in potency in the absence of
BRCA2. This is not experienced by BET bromodomain
inhibition. But we see this nice preserved
synthetic lethality.
And that toxicity is totally removed by
inverting the stereochemistry on the JQ1 portion of these small
molecules. The stereoisomer can't engage BET
bromodomains. And we see no cell viability effects with the
small molecule, suggesting that although we're not stoichiometrically engaging
BET bromodomains, it is required for the mechanism of action, suggesting that
maybe there was some sort of heterobifunctional activity
elicited by these cells or by these compounds.
But to confirm that we actually do create a ternary complex, we designed
a FRET-based assay to look at proximity between PARP and
BRD4. And here we see a very
typical hook effect suggestive of induced proximity
that is ablated by the inverted
stereoisomer, the enantiomer of PSIP1.
And so we can confirm that at least in vitro, these small molecules do
elicit a ternary complex.
And the same holds true in cells. So if you do a BRD4
pull-down and look for co-elution of
PARP1 and PARP2, we see that only in the presence of PSIP1, not in either of
the monovalent controls or the inactive enantiomer.
And if you do the reverse pull-down PARP2, we see BRD4 come along
with it.
So in vitro and in cells, we can
see evidence of ternary complex formation by PSIP1.
And this, as we expected based on the synthetic lethality with HR
deficiencies, leads to a very potent inhibition of DNA damage
repair. So in the presence of an exogenous
source of DNA damage with this MMS-...
chemical mutagen, we see that rucaparib inhibits
polyolation by PARP1 and creates a high
burden of DNA damage as read out by gamma-H2AX.
And the same thing is seen with PSIP1,
confirming that these molecules are most likely working through some sort of
DNA damage response, and that correlates with
a cell cycle arrest in the S phase, which is quite similar
to PARP inhibition.
And if you perform a prism assay with the Broad Institute, we see an incredibly
high correlation between PSIP1 and selective PARP1
inhibitors like sinaprib,
the top correlated compounds of over 25,000 comparisons.
And this follows a dose-response relationship where at low concentrations of
the compound, we see a very high correlation with PARP inhibition.
At very high concentrations, we start to see things correlate with BET bromodomain
inhibition, but I think that's a nice confirmation that the molecule's not
functioning as a BET bromodomain inhibitor, at least when we're careful about the
concentrations that we use them at, which we are.
And this was an unexpected result to us.
We did not anticipate that BET recruitment would be cytotoxic or that it would
inhibit DNA damage repair. And so we've had a number of questions about how
this effect could be caused in the cells.
One thought was that maybe this leads to PARP1 trapping,
like conventional PARP inhibitors, and that that's the source of the
cytotoxicity. But we very quickly ruled that out.
In fact, if you knock out PARP1, the cells become more sensitive to PSIP1,
quite opposite of the control compound here, talazoparib, where you see a rapid
emergence of resistance. We actually see an improved sensitivity of these
cells to PSIP1.
So we thought, "Well, maybe it's PARP2 then.
I don't know why, but it could be." And we knocked out PARP2, and indeed, that gave
very rapid resistance to PSIP1, not something that we see with other PARP
inhibitors.
And so then we
became quite convinced that the ternary complex formed
between BET bromodomain proteins and PARP2 is the source of toxicity,
and PARP1, which is quite a bit more abundant in the cells,
might act as a sink for the compound, a non-functional sink.
When we form a ternary complex with PARP1, it doesn't do anything.
And so in the absence of this very abundant protein, we get improved
cytotoxicity.
Indeed, when you knock out PARP2, PSIP1 is no longer able to inhibit the
repair of DNA damage. We see the loss of gamma-H2AX in
the absence of PARP2. And we have this very nice chemical control where we
can titrate increasing concentrations of several PARP inhibitors that
all have equivalent PARP1 potency but vary in their
PARP2 affinities by over three orders of magnitude and ask
at
what concentrations do these compounds block the effects of PARP2,
presumably by engaging--
or PSIP1, but presumably by engaging PARP2.
And we see that their ability to block the effects of PSIP1
correlate directly with their affinities for PARP2.
So the weakest rescuer is cerubrib, the most selective
PARP1 inhibitor of the bunch.
Now, this is very important to us in understanding the mechanism of action of these
small molecules, but I think there's an important therapeutic point to make here,
which is that resistance in cell culture, for sure, and
there's evidence of this in papers as well,
emerges to PARP inhibitors by inactivation of PARP1, knockout,
decreased expression, loss of function mutations that block drug binding.
And so
we see our molecule as an opportunity to actually improve the therapeutic
window of agents that are used in HR deficiencies in the
context of acquired resistance to PARP1 agents, either
through sequential or concurrent therapeutic.
You could imagine
averting this mechanism of resistance.
So what do these molecules do beyond recruit BET proteins?
We have a few clues. As I said, we still have a number of questions as well,
so I hope you'll bear with me.
We ran an IP-MS experiment on PARP2 to
ask what happens to its interactome in the presence of this small molecule.
We see most clearly the recruitment of BET proteins,
and that's not observed with the controls as expected.
But we also see a number of other proteins or protein complexes
that are involved in DNA damage repair.
So five members of the INO80 chromatin remodeler complex
that's involved in DNA repair and transcription, ATAD5,
XSC10. These proteins are brought to PARP2 in the
presence of PSIP1, but not with rucaparib.
So it's not just a general mechanism of repair of DNA damage sites.
It seems to be specific to this bifunctional mechanism of action.
And we can confirm that in Western blot co-IP experiments,
where even in the presence of MMS, rucaparib and JQ1 are not
able to recruit these proteins to PARP2.
So potentially that's involved in the mechanism.
We're still exploring that. Certainly, it's a fingerprint, I
think, of these small molecules and how they're working.
We've been quite fortunate to explore the mechanism further in collaboration with
Dan Darzhay's group, led by Ash. Dan
has,
of course, very notable work in the field of DNA damage repair, particularly
in recent years using genetic screening approaches to try to understand the
mechanism of action of chemical mutagens and
small molecule inhibitors that target DNA damage repair pathways.
And they've previously characterized a few dozen
DNA-damaging agents, which gives you a fingerprint of the types of DNA,
the pathways that are sort of elicited by these agents.
And so we collaborated with his group to perform an unbiased, full genome
CRISPR-based modifier screen to look at genetic knockouts that might confer
resistance or increase sensitivity to PSIP1.And there's a lot
on this very busy slide.
But I think there's a number of important points that I want to draw your attention
to. First, we see that knockout of BRCA
confers sensitivity to both rucaparib and PSIP1, increased
sensitivity. So we had some confidence that this screen had worked quite
appropriately. We also see recapitulation of the PARP1 and PARP2 data,
but only for PSIP1 in this case. So if you knock out PARP1, you get increased
sensitivity, PARP2, you get resistance.
Then there's this ABCC1 knockout, which we know from
the PROTAC field often increases the
effective concentration of heterobifunctional small molecules in the cell.
That was specific to PSIP1. So we think the screen worked quite well.
And I think what has really captured our attention are
these really screaming hits on the SUMO
machinery.
PIAS4, a SUMO ligase, SEMP1, SUMO2,
all conferring selective cytotoxicity or increased
cytotoxicity to PSIP1 and not rucaparib.
This is true of the other controls also.
We screened JQ1, we screened the enantiomer of PSIP1, and these hits
are exquisitely selective for PSIP1.
In fact,
we went through Dan's previous data sets and saw
that these agents are unlike anything else that they have seen
before.
You could see that PSIP1, although it creates similar
downstream effects as PARP inhibitors, it is quite uncorrelated
with the effects of the PARP inhibitors that they have screened in the past.
It seems to be clustering with cisplatin, not because we think it works like
cisplatin, but just to highlight the fact that it doesn't cluster with PARP
inhibitors.
And if you look at some of these top hits that came out of the screen, CHD1L,
which is ALC1,
PARP1, PARP2, PIAS4, SEMP1, these hits have not shown up in any
of their previous screens. So I think we're
engaging quite a new mechanism of action with these small molecules.
One thought is that they might be causing PARP2
chromatin trapping, PARP2 and BRD4, actually.
There are a number of small molecules that, like PARP inhibitors, are known to
immobilize proteins onto chromatin.
Hypomethylating agents that create protein DNA crosslinks, topoisomerase
inhibitors, Vurner degraders that first function by trapping
Vurner on DNA, as well as these DNMT1 reversible
inhibitors and SERDs, as we're learning more and
more each day.
The interesting thing about these examples is that they all,
at some point, seem to interface with SUMO
machinery. In some cases, it's not entirely clear whether the SUMO machinery
is cause or consequence of the trapping, but
it seems to be implicated in many of these agents.
And so the fact that we pulled out these SUMO hits from our screen
was quite conspicuous.
The other thing that we pulled out is this ALC1 hit, which others have
shown knockout of ALC1 creates a
specific increased ability of PARP inhibitors to trap
PARP2 rather than PARP1. And so
all of this together made us wonder whether the PSIP molecules might somehow be
creating PARP2 trapping. Now, if it does, this can't be going through a
stoichiometric occupancy of the PARP2 ligand binding site.
We know these molecules only get to 5%
engagement at any one point.
But through the recruitment of VET proteins, we're somehow potentially eliciting
PARP2 trapping. Indeed, if we knock out ALC1, we can confirm that the
cells become more sensitive
to PSIP1, suggesting a role for PARP2.
And if you perform chromatin fractionation experiments, we see
quite selective
trapping or increased enrichment of PARP2 on the
chromatin fraction. I regret not having a laser pointer for you on this
very busy blot here, but we see a movement
of BRD4 and PARP2 away from the nuclear soluble
fraction into the chromatin fraction only in the presence of
PSIP1.
So we have many clues, sort of like Colonel Mustard in the kitchen.
We just don't know if it's the candlestick yet.
But we're
quite excited about the possibility that
we can find these unanticipated,
unexpected mechanisms of action by just putting different
proteins and pathways of the cell together in
somewhat random ways,
said condescendingly if you're Reviewer Two.
But I think that that randomness is actually a huge opportunity to
explore the sort of untapped potential of the
cell's machinery to turn it against itself.
With that, I will thank our
funding sources.
The students and postdocs that led this work have done a really
fantastic job bringing us into a new area
of science,
and all of our really wonderful collaborators on this project and others.
I think I've gone a bit faster than I expected, so I'm happy to take
any questions. Thanks.
Michael, really interesting talk. Over here.
Here.
Okay. Sorry.
So if you've got any idea or if you've been able to characterize how long
these ternary complexes might reside.
That is a bit of a mystery to me. I
was surprised by how strongly we can see
ternary complex formation in co-IP and IP-MS,
despite the incredibly weak binary interactions, and
maybe those are just very sensitive assays.
But I think there's another possibility here
that-After a ternary complex formation,
you create some effect that leads to an indirect
increased
recruitment of these proteins together.
This is highly speculative, but
I do wonder if the recruitment of BET proteins is actually activating
transcription at sites of DNA damage and silencing transcription.
This is one of the first things that needs to be done when you repair DNA.
And potentially, these replication
transcription conflicts and formation of R-loops might be leading to increased
association of these proteins, and there's some kind of snowball effect, which is
quite hand-wavy, but we have some real mysteries there.
But I don't know exactly how long-lived the ternary complexes are.
There's a number of ways you could explore that, right?
Just FRAP/FAS tests or other ways that you could explore how long these things are
together. It might be worth a look.
Certainly. Yeah. Absolutely.
So over here. Nice talk.
Along the lines of that question, do your co-IPs require
DNA?
Is DNA coming down or is RNA coming down?
It comes back to your original premise.
Yeah. It's a great question.
We don't have that data, but I'm going to do that experiment now.
So we ran that with FOXA1, where you strip the cell of-
Yeah, RNAs
... nucleic acids with benzonase, right? And yeah, we'll do that.
A nice talk. And
have you explored the other way, like
the PARP2
affecting the function of BRD4 and
explored a
stoichiometry between BRD4 and--
Absolutely. Yeah, that's a great question. So we have.
We've profiled the transcriptional effects of these small molecules quite
extensively, and they really have minimal transcriptional effects.
They are the same transcriptional effects as the enantiomer that doesn't do
anything. So I don't think that a bulk effect on
gene transcription is what's driving the effect of these small molecules.
As I mentioned, I think there might be some involvement in transcription at sites
of DNA damage in a non-gene specific way.
And we know they're not acting as BET bromodomain inhibitors.
Fortunately, we know exactly what genes are affected by BET bromodomain inhibition,
and that's not what we're seeing here.
Now, I don't know if PARP2 gets recruited to sites where BRD4
usually binds. There's some possibility that through having two
bromodomains, that might be possible.
But I don't suspect that that's the driver of the
effects that we see.
Okay. Thank you.
Hi, Michael. Very nice talk.
We are
developing the five-million small molecule, also target
the BRD4 and the PARP, yeah, using the
olaparib linked with the JK1. And we are
working on the mechanism. So I'm very interested
in your work about the PARP2
trapping. Yeah. We
have the idea about the gain-of-function.
Do you think it's a gain-of-function is a main mechanism
for the
recording the BRD4 to the PAR binding site and
activate the transcription or generating the
R-loop? Yeah.
Yes.
Are you asking if
that's what we think is happening, the formation of R-loops?
Yeah.
We're working on that. I think so. One of the hits that we found in the screen was
RNase H2,
and that's involved in resolving these R-loops, right?
So I think that there's a very strong chance that
transcription replication conflicts leading to R-loops-
Yeah
... is involved in the mechanism, yeah.
Yeah. And
I was wondering, the PSIP, just you
need to use MS to generate more DNA
breaks, then you can generate the gamma
H2X to interrupt the DNA repair. So
I was wondering this drug's advantage
compared to the other
PARP inhibitor. Yeah.
Yeah. I think that they lead to the same place.
It's a different path to the waterfall, right?
The preserved synthetic lethality and
cytotoxic signature being so well correlated with selective PARP1
inhibitors, I think leads to the same place.
The questions are going to be whether the toxicities are overlapping
or not.
But the greatest potential, if they have
similar toxicities,
is the possibility of combining hyperselective
PARP1 inhibitors-
Mm-hmm
... with PSIPs that function through PARP2 as a way to get
combined therapeutic activity.
Okay. Thank you. Yeah.
Thanks.
All right.
That will be it for me then. And next up, we will have, I
think it's
William Gibson.
Thanks for the suspense. Thanks, Will.
Thanks so much, Mike. If I can get the pointer to work this time.
All right.
Is the keyboard connected?
No.
This thing?
Yeah.
Okay. There's no pointer?
It's not.
All right.
Well, thanks so much, Mike, and thank you all for coming to this educational
session.
So what I thought I'd do today is give a little overview of where I think the field
sits now outside of targeted protein degradation and a little bit of how our
work fits in.So I think giving this
talk,
in the past, you'd say there's this distinction between the
occupancy-based paradigm and
the proximity-based paradigm, where we say that we used to be able to design small
molecules that would occupy enzymes in the past, block their
activity, but now with TPD, we could potentially degrade any
protein. So the degradable or affectable number of
proteins went from low thousands to potentially any
protein in principle.
But I think since about 2019, 2020, we started
realizing that there are a lot more functions beside degradation and the phenocopy
of genetic knockout that would be pharmacologically interesting and therapeutically
interesting to us.
So I think now we're thinking a lot more about proximity beyond
TPD.
And the goals for today would be to go over an overview of some of
these advances in induced proximity and with a focus on some of these
molecules that are heading to and penetrating the clinic.
I'm sure we'll talk a lot about that this AACR,
and touch on a few places where we've been working on this.
So bifunctional molecules can, I think in principle,
do two main things. One is bind the unbindable, and here's just a little screen
cap from Greg Verdine's, I think, landmark
paper on convincing FKBP to wrap
around this
protein that is entirely featureless leucine zipper.
And they can also confer neo-function, which is degradation,
phosphorylation, or any of the other PTMs and things we'll talk about a little bit
today.
So the first category is we can convince these small molecules
to bind to new targets, and I think the
poster child for this is daxinrasib, which has made huge
news the past week.
And the importance of this is that you can bind something that really doesn't have
any pocket, so to speak, and that's by bringing a new surface area to wrap around
the target and bring what is physically needed for this sort of affinity
interaction even beyond covalency.
So here we have cyclophilin A binding to the
daxinrasib,
forming a
bifunctional complex, and then that ternary complex can then form,
coaxed with a lot of the PPIs from the cyclophilin
A Ras-on interaction.
And this has become important therapeutically, as we've realized
with the recent publication of these data.
So this all started in May '22. The first patients were enrolled in the phase
1/2, 83 patients were in the second line for PDAC, where
we saw an overall response rate of 35%.
Then moved to the registrational trial.
First patients enrolled in October 2024, and just announced this past
week in the RASalute-302 data, there was a
hazard ratio of 0.4 with a
very small P value in these patients against standard of care,
investigator's choice. This is now being moved to non-small
cell lung cancer,
going up against docetaxel.
But we're seeing even better results when we move up to patients that are no longer
refractory to standard therapies.
And so in the first phase 1/2 in these PDAC patients, just about 40 patients, we
see an overall response rate of about 50%.
And now with RASalute-303, deraxinrasib
monotherapy going up against a chemo combo.
I think some of the most interesting data will be this RASalute-304 study,
500 patients intended. It's going to be daxinrasib monotherapy versus
chemo combination.
So I think that we have really exciting times ahead in binding the unbindable,
because some of these cancer dependencies have been
heretofore undrugged due to our chemical constraints.
So now we've done a lot, in endless seminars before I've
talked about TPD. But you can do the reverse, which is
targeted protein stabilization by using
deubiquitinases and their recruitment.
So typically, if you catch a protein in the process of
its being degraded and polyubiquitinated, you can knock off some of
those ubiquitins by recruitment of a deubiquitinase.
This was largely investigated earliest in Dan Nomura's lab.
And here's one of the molecules that they pioneered, a CFTR ligand, a
small linker, and then an OTUB1 recruiter, showing that when you add
this molecule to cells, you can stabilize CFTR
for intended therapeutic benefit.
And several companies have launched in this space, Stablx, Vicinitas, and
Intact Bio. So it'll be interesting to see how the coin flip of
targeted protein degradation progresses into the clinic.
And other PTMs have, of course, been explored as well.
One of the most important PTMs we know of is phosphorylation.
So Amit Chowdhury's lab has pioneered a lot of this work where you take a
targeted protein and a ligand to it, recruit a
kinase,
and through this increased effective molarity, you can phosphorylate the
protein. Here's one of their earliest molecules
that recruited AMPK to JQ1. And you can see
here in this in vitro reconstitution assay, there's essentially no phosphorylation
in the DMSO-treated
condition and a very high phosphorylation with their compound.
They've since done some really interesting chemistry because most of the kinase
recruiters we have are active site recruiters, of course.
But he's pioneered this really interesting approach where they call it GRIPS,
where you can use it to do a group transfer reaction to have the small
molecule that occupies the site leave as the leaving group and
keep your bifunctional molecule tethered there to recruit new substrates.
So I think this area is going to be really interesting in the future.
Fotis was founded in 2021 to commercialize Fix, and it will be
interesting to see where they go.Now, one new
chapter we're interested in is targeted protein
relocalization.
The
cell compartmentalizes many proteins to already increase their molarity,
and taking protein from one compartment to another, we think can
substantially change the biology.
So as a proof of principle, we took
a small molecule that binds to FKBP, and then reasoned that maybe we
could grab proteins that have a nuclear localization signal and
piggyback off of their nuclear localization signal to enter the nucleus.
And one of those compounds, as everyone knows, in our induced
proximity field, is our favorite protein, BRD4.
So we picked the constitutively nuclear and highly
abundant nuclear protein, BRD4, synthesized
JQ1, connected to this
FKBP ligand, and we're able to show that you can take
FKBP-tagged proteins and bring them into the
nucleus. So in this one example that I'm showing here, we
take
mutant nucleophosmin, which has a new neo-nuclear export
signal and is constitutively localized and pathologically
localized to the cytoplasm, and drag it into the nucleus.
So here you can see the cell starts out with cytosolic
NPM1c, and then when we add our compound, it relocalizes
very quickly to the nucleus and also into cytosolic
condensates.
Dr. Banik, who will speak after me, has also done some pioneering work in this
field,
synthesizing a large variety of these molecules that he may talk about,
and showing really convincingly that there's a large number of proteins that can be
used as shuttlers, like nuclear hormone receptors, METAB2, and actually
PARP1.
I think there's another chapter of induced proximity things that are maybe a little
bit less prescriptive. Not a PTM,
not localization, just sort of this weird things happen.
So I'll talk about a few of these. One
is we call TSIPs, which are things that can
influence transcription.
So Nat Gray and Gerry Crabtree have pioneered this really
amazing work where
theorizing that if you take a DNA-binding protein that's localized to certain
segments of the genome and then recruit the transcriptional machinery, you can
activate transcription there, which is
easy enough in theory, but hard in practice, and
largely in parallel to yeast two-hybrid screens, but now doing it
with small molecules. So they focused on the protein BCL6
and its ligandable
BTB domain, and in their first study, recruited BRD4
to these regions. Now, BCL6 is
typically a repressor. It's involved in translocations in lymphomas,
and the idea is that if you can flip the switch on this repressor, you can have a
therapeutic impact.
So they synthesized these molecules that bind to BCL6 on one
side, BRD4 on the other, and showed that you can get killing in these
lymphoma models at doses of about one nanomolar.
What was really interesting here, in particular, I think, is the potency.
You see the induction of transcription at BCL6
targets. So here they set up this reporter system with all these BCL6 repeats
transcribing GFP, and when you add the compound they call TSIP1,
you get very high induction of GFP.
And that when you do ChIP-seq, you can see BRD4 very convincingly
moving to these BCL6 bound loci,
and that when you give these compounds in vivo,
you can see really impressive transcriptomic
changes in the cells that carry large numbers of B cells that are dependent on
BCL6, and much more modest changes in other
tissues like liver and lung.
They've since moved this to other transcriptional machinery,
using BCL6 binders,
recruiting CDK9 to them with these active site binders.
And I think the latest version are these p300 recruiting
TSIPs, where the
potency is even higher. And we'll talk about p300 a little bit later.
I think one question that we're all interested in is what other
DNA binding domains can we use after BCL6, because I think it'd be really
nice to port this story over to many more applications.
Now, there's a story that was sort of this, I don't know if I'd call it a slow
burn,
but started from this really interesting observation, just profiling lots of
chemicals at the Broad Institute against lots of cell lines.
And one of the observations was that there's these phosphodiesterase
3 inhibitors that were causing death in a large number of cell lines, and it was
sort of just inexplicable at first.
So here you can see certain cell lines dying at very low doses of this compound,
others at very high nonspecific doses.
And what was found is when you do this sort of, I call it cancer cell line
epidemiology, you just correlate gene expression of everything versus
potency. Phosphodiesterase 3 expression correlated
very highly with the potency of these compounds.
Then in later studies,
they showed that if you do a CRISPR screen on these compounds in sensitive cell
lines, three proteins really rise to the top,
phosphodiesterase 3, Slufn 12, and AIP.
The role of AIP has not yet been established for these compounds.
But then you can do a cryo-EM structure.
You show that when you add these compounds, immunoprecipitate PDE3A, you get
Slufn 12 out. And then you can do a cryo-EM of
this newly constituted structure and see that
PDE3A, which is a dimer, reconstitutes Slufn 12,
which is also a dimer, but now an active
RNase.It turns out that if you do
unbiased RNA sequencing, including tRNAs, that it's the
leucine tRNAs that get degraded when you
add this compound. And you can even reconstitute this tRNA
degradation in vitro to show that adding this
compound causes this complex to form, cuts all the tRNAs,
and then you actually lose the ability to produce proteins in these cells.
So these compounds were called Velcans by the Greulich and Meyerson
groups at Dana-Farber and Broad Institute.
And so through a collaboration with Bayer Pharmaceuticals, they actually brought
these compounds to clinic. So they optimized these compounds
for their pKpd and potency,
and then brought them to the clinic.
And you can see here they did their
initial dose-finding studies.
And what was found is that very quickly, within a week, these patients dropped
their platelet counts precipitously.
So it turns out these patients were
initially tried in melanoma, which has very high expression of PD3A and Slufn 12,
that
the compounds were killing megakaryocytes.
And then you'd see the platelet drop about a week later because platelets have a
half-life of about a week.
And if you go back to the very first panels from the original
Velcan papers, you can see there's some PD3A inhibitors that are
non-toxic, some that are. And amongst those that are, is a compound called
anagrelide. Anagrelide has been
FDA approved as a treatment for thrombocythemia
to reduce platelets when they're pathologically high.
So something I think we keep seeing in the induced proximity field is that
what's old is new, what's new is old,
with thalidomide, lenalidomide, and now Velcans, is that you keep
rediscovering these really interesting PPIs and these small molecules that
induce them.
So
it turned out that this was hiding under our nose all this time.
Now switching topics to another set of induced
proximity
phenotypes that we think is really interesting is this discovery of this Riptak
principle. So Craig Crews and how the therapeutics showed that
if you take cancers overexpressing a certain protein and design small
molecules that are targeting this protein, and then also bearing
a molecule that targets some essential protein, you
can see dramatically enhanced toxicity in the cells that are
overexpressing what they call the target protein, here depicted in
purple.
So all you need is this, for selectivity, is to find a protein that's highly
overabundant in the cancer cells.
So here in their cell chemical biology paper in 2024, they
show if you take a parental cell line, overexpress
FKBP, and then use these bifunctional ligands, you can get a really
interesting therapeutic index. And here the essential protein
is a CDK inhibitor.
Now they have progressed this to the clinic in, I think, a really impressive way.
So their first set of products was
bifunctional compounds that were targeting the androgen receptor,
and bringing BRD4 as the essential protein to it.
So this is Halda 0915. So January,
2023 was the Riptak preprint. And very quickly, they
got to clinic in 2025 with their trial launch.
October 25, they got these trial results, which we'll go over.
So this is their dose-finding study.
At 50 milligrams daily dose, you can see they reached
very high efficacy. And what was really impressive to me was not just this
waterfall plot, but these were patients that were already castrate resistant.
Androgen receptor had been inhibited every which way before these patients were
enrolled. So presumably, these tumors were
resistant to
a loss of androgen signaling. And when you look at these patients, you actually
see that lots of them have AR ligand binding mutations, even the ones that
responded. And lots of them are expressing ARV7, lacking this
ligand binding domain entirely. So
presumably,
this cannot be due to a loss of AR signaling.
It has to be due to the presence of the wild-type proteins in these
cells, and then this gain of function pharmacology where you're
bringing BRD4 to them. So just
one month after they presented these results, they were acquired for three billion
by J&J.
And so one thought we've had is, can we apply these learnings to other cancer
proteins?
And one protein where we've been excited about applying these concepts is with
P53.
So P53 is the most mutated protein across all
cancers, and it's not really close.
And it's the worst mutation to have, too.
So on the right-hand side of this plot, you can see a bunch of genetic subtypes of
acute myeloid leukemia, and the patients who actually die of their disease are the
patients with P53 mutations. So when you add all this up, that's about five
million patients per year that die of P53 mutant disease.
P53 mutations are fairly interesting in a few ways, but one is
that for most tumor suppressors, they're knocked out by
nonsense or frame shift mutations, but P53,
75% of these mutations are missense mutations.
And that's because these mutations,
95% of them occur in the DNA binding domain, and you need the full
tetramer to wrap around DNA at the right sites in the genome.
And if any one of those tetrameric subunits is
mutated, you lose that DNA binding ability at the right places.
So it's a faster path for P53 to take these
missense dominant negative mutations.
So
we've looked in the past for synthetic lethals against P53 and
never found any. So if you ask yourself, what is different about P53 mutant
cells versus wild-type cells, you really only come up with one thing.
So when you do quantitative proteomics across the whole proteome,
you see that only one protein is increased in abundance, and that's P53
itself. And that's because there's this tight feedback loop between
MDM2 and P53, and when you lose P53's ability
to transcribe MDM2, you build up very high levels of
P53.So here is what that looks like
across the Cancer Cell Line Encyclopedia.
All the cell lines that have missense mutations of p53 have very high
abundance of p53 protein on the Y-axis.
And
this is actually how we used to diagnose p53 mutant cancers, which is we would do
IHC for p53. So on the right, you can see an
ovarian cancer sample, H&E on the left, p53 staining on the right.
The normal stroma has essentially zero p53. The cancer cells have a lot of it.
So when I see a
immunohistochemistry like that, I think, "Well, that's a therapeutic window I can
work with." So the idea is that we need a
drug that kills cells in proportion of p53 abundance, and the molecular glue and
RIP-TAG framework fits that bill.
So we designed small molecules looking through the patent literature that could
bind to p53. And we know that there's no molecules that can
bind to wild type p53 or pockets that are
native to a large variety of mutants.
But there are molecules that can bind to the Y220C mutant.
So we designed a molecule that
binds to this Y220C mutant and recruits PLK1, which is
a highly essential mitotic kinase.
We were able to show that you can get specific cell death in these cells that bear
the Y220C mutation and not those that bear other
p53 mutations, and that you don't see any effect from either of the
monomeric binders, PLK1 inhibitors or the
p53 binder itself.
We can see that you can easily reconstitute a ternary complex
formation in NanoBiT assays,
and that when you add excess of the monomeric binder you
can rescue some of the toxicity. So we do think that this is a gain of function
pharmacology that's dependent on the ternary complex.
When we add our compound to cells, we observed that of course the
p53 refolder can induce
p53 transcriptional activation.
But when we add the bivalent compound, we don't see that it's working through
p53
recovery of its function.
And instead, we think that-- So here you can see a heat map of
p53 targets, the PMV6 compound which is from
PMV Pharma, now in risatapapt in clinical trials, can reactivate
these target genes. But the bivalent molecule that brings PLK1
to p53 does not, and is likely acting much
more through PLK1 inhibition in a RIP-TAG-like manner.
So now I'll transition to a new story that we just put
out in a preprint, which is
that some of these molecules you think you can intend to work
one way, and it actually turns out they have a few different functions.
So
the same bifunctional compound can be a TSIP, a RIP-TAG, a degrader, and a
whole bunch of other things. So I'll go through how we
learned about this.
So we were trying to find small molecules or do a comprehensive assessment
of what are the best warheads you could use to recruit transcription.
So we had used an IRF1 reporter. We used
FKBP tagged IRF1 to drag transcriptional
machinery through a variety of different warheads to
IRF1. And what we found was the most potent warhead
was this p300 recruiting warhead called GNE-781.
It's at the top of this plot here, ATAC2.
So we tried to do a little linkerology with the different linkers
depicted here. And what we saw was that
we get transactivation in the IRF1 reporter and dose response studies.
You can compete off this transactivation with excess binder.
It's characteristic of these ternary complexes.
And that you can bring
CBP
in ternary complex and NanoBiT assays.
And so what we thought is, okay, so we have a small molecule that can activate
transcriptional machinery. And we thought, well, what are some models where we
could try this therapeutically? And one model that's been used in the past that I
think I thought was really compelling is a model of therapeutic overactivation.
So it's been known since about 2002 that if you overexpress
EWS-FLI, the Ewing sarcoma oncogene in fibroblasts, that
they'll die off if you express at high levels.
And if you knock out the ubiquitin ligase for EWS-FLI,
TRIM8, then the cells will also die.
So we thought maybe we can add our compound, overactivate
EWS-FLI, and have a therapeutic response.
And it turned out when we did RNA sequencing with this
GNE-871 compound that we saw a decrease in the
EWS-FLI program.
And I asked my student a few times, "Did you mix up the tubes?" We went
back, tried it again, got the same result.
And it turned out it was really real, that this compound was not actually inducing
transcription. It was actually inducing a loss of the transcriptional program.
So we scratched our heads and tried all the things.
We found out that the compound was degrading EWS-FLI.
You can see in this Western blot here.
But what was also happening is that
EWS-FLI, which typically recruits p300
to EWS-FLI bound sites, was actually exchanging CBP.
So when we did ChIP-seq, we saw recruitment of CBP, loss of
p300 peaks.
And that when we repeated these experiments with just
FKBP GFP knocked into these cells rather than the EWS-FLI with
FKBP, we could find the same toxic effects.
And so what we
thought this molecule was going to act as a TSIP, we actually saw that it was
acting as a RIP-TAG and a degrader of the
fusion oncogene.
And the lesson here is that bifunctional compounds don't just have one mode of
action. They can do a lot of things at once, and you really have to do the work to
piece it all out.
So with that, I just want to wrap up and thank all my lab
members, especially Ananth Than, who did the work on the
ATAC story and the p53 story. And I want to thank our funding,
especially the Briger Foundation.
And please feel free to reach out, and I'll take any questions.
Very nice talk. I just have a question.
So for the RIP-tag, you're using p53.
You're using a binder which specifically binds the mutated
p53.
Considering the high expression of p53
in mutant cells, is that possible to use a
binder and the wild type p53 as still have
a therapeutic window, do you think?
Yeah. So we did some experiments there in proof of concept
systems using
tagged versions of mutant and wild type p53, and we still
see a good therapeutic index there.
So one of the areas of focus for us is trying to extend
this framework to pan-p53 sort of
RIP-tags and molecular glues.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you for the introductory section and
sharing your beautiful data.
I was wondering about your introductory session.
From the localization case, you showed us
that FKBP is recruited to BRD4's
location, and next case, neo functions
for TCIP. BRD4 is recruited to
BCL6 location. Why does this
difference between these two cases?
Could you share your insight to this difference?
Oh.
So the same BRD4-
Yeah
... when partnering with two proteins,
BRD4
looks.
Yeah. It's a good question. I think there's a few things.
I think a lot of this has to do with the molarity of the two proteins in all of
these systems, is that typically the one with higher molarity is going
to win or-
Molarity
... localization.
The abundance.
Yeah.
Oh, thank you.
Hello. Adam from Aurum Therapeutics.
For the p53 degrader, do you require the cells to have
one copy of the wild type p53 for that to work?
No. So yeah, a lot of p53 mutants are heterozygous,
and you still see the accumulation of the protein.
I think what we saw is that the p53 refolders work very well
in the context of
where they're heterozygous where you have a wild type ligand.
But if you have two mutants, like a second hotspot with the
Y220C mutation, the refolders don't work at all, which makes sense.
But we see the gain of function compounds work there as well.
I think I'm still missing a piece of the logic.
You're
degrading a tumor suppressor?
I'm sorry. It's not a degrader. It's a
RIP-tag.
Ah.
You can bring in additional toxicity by binding
to p53.
Ah. Thank you.
All right. Thank you, guys.
Thank you, Will. Next, we'll have
Steven Banik come and talk more about proximity pharmacology.
All right. Thank you very much.
So Will did a really great job talking about
the evolution of bifunctional molecules.
And so I figured I would do something a little bit different and think about how
we discover molecules for induced proximity in the first place.
So,
I would say that bifunctional molecules have really been the heart of
induced proximity therapeutic development.
So as we saw, they allow us to go all the way
from protein degradation strategies, where you can think about recruiting
ubiquitin ligase machinery or directly bringing proteins to a
subcellular compartment for destruction,
to then thinking about how we can maybe induce broader post-translational
modification rewiring
to enforce signaling or create neo functions or attenuate
signaling. And then
this continuum allows us to get to a
space where we can maybe remove considerations entirely
about a bespoke function. Does it need to add or remove a
covalent group to actually do something?
And so I think we're now seeing that even just bringing two proteins together in
unique ways allows for a large number of
rewiring events.
And so in this space of bringing proteins together, I
think the reason bifunctionals have been so attractive is because it really allows
us to program this behavior in some way.
We can take known ligands or known proteins, couple them together,
and yes, linkerology is
maybe arduous, but it is something that we can perform readily.
We can make lots of compounds by taking known ligands and putting them together.
And where this has gone to now, I think, is
trying to find molecules where when you bring them together, induces an extra
element of cooperativity in that engagement.
So moving away from this idea that these two proteins
don't have any inherent interactions to finding molecules that maybe induce them
to have some sort of affinity interaction as well.
And these bifunctional molecules come in lots of different flavors for lots of
different purposes.
So of course, our ability to do this requires that we have ligands.
And at some point, we're going to run out of ligands to start putting things
together and to rewire biology. So how do we discover new molecules?
And I would say there are a few different
camps. I would say one major camp is this idea of ligand first.
You think about trying to find any binder for your protein of
interest and then repurpose that.
And so DNA encoded library technology, I think, has really emerged
as the major way of doing large amounts of bio-panning for any
molecular matter that sticks to your protein of interest.
This idea of cooperativity, though, in bifunctional molecules, has really sort
ofinstigated a desire to screen for
cooperativity in the first place.
And so I think more recent approaches are sort of targeting this
idea that maybe what we should do is use DNA-encoded libraries with
one partner protein already attached to your ligand with some exposed
interface that a second partner protein could come engage.
And by doing that, maybe bias to find cooperative compounds and maybe even
molecular glues.
So this idea of ligand first, I think is very interesting.
It allows you to do a large number of scalable experiments, but it is separated
from the cellular environment where you actually want your molecule to operate in
the first place. And I think anyone would understand that there are a
lot of complexities that go into what has to happen in a cell for an
induced proximity event to occur, and also how binding can change in the
cellular environment. So in a solvent of ATP, how does
engagement with proteins change for small molecule ligands?
So phenotypic screens or function first screens, I think, are really
attractive.
And so they allow you to broadly profile a large number of molecules, figure out if
they're doing something interesting in the first place, and then chase that
mechanism down using--
It used to be really careful biochemical fractionation experiments.
Now we've lost that ability, and we just do unbiased screens to figure out how
things work.
Our ability to do function first is defined
by, do we have a phenotype that we care about? Often that can be cell death.
But what about induced proximity, where maybe you want to look at something
else other than induced cell death?
You need to expand the range of phenotypes that you can look at through a function
first mechanism.
And so in the field of protein degradation, where we're looking for molecules that
will down-regulate a protein, I think everyone would say we have good strategies
for looking at that on a small number of compounds.
Obviously, immunoblots are a fantastic tool.
That's actually one I ran myself.
Some people would say that there's a difference between 15% and 28%, as I've shown
in red. I would say there's no difference.
I would say there's almost no difference between 50% and 20% or
10%. And that's because the immunoblot is obviously a great
tool, but it's a
somewhat subjective tool.
Flow cytometry is really exciting, right?
It allows us to look at the single molecule level about how something might be
changing. So you fuse your protein of interest to a fluorescent reporter, and you
look for changes in abundance. And you can do that somewhat scalably
across single cells, although it starts to have diminished returns when you think
about trying to scale it up. Then proteomics is fantastic.
It gives us a huge snapshot of a number of different abundance changes that are
happening in cells, a function of a molecule treatment.
The sensitivity might be no better than what a western blot might be,
but allows us to look at a larger swath of proteins. Okay?
I would say all of these are limited in their ability to look at molecules
and other phenotypes at scale. So,
no one's going to run 10,000 western blots in triplicate probably to do a
high-throughput screen. And if you are, please talk to me, because we
can fix that.
Flow cytometry and high-throughput flow cytometry has really emerged as something
that's quite exciting. But then you still have a statistical significance problem.
As you go to high throughput and you try to go faster for flow cytometry, you start
to lose statistical significance for what you can draw from any small molecule
screen. So you start to lose that sensitivity that makes flow cytometry so
attractive in the first place.
And then proteomics, while you might be able to buy yourself a farm of mass
spectrometers and be operating them continuously for several years at a time,
it's just hard to screen a huge number of molecules to get statistical power
to say that small changes are something that you can say for real.
And so what my lab is really excited by is this idea that maybe we should think
about how to develop more scalable technologies for finding molecules or profiling
entire biological pathways. And so where I would say scalable technologies are
really needed is in this high-throughput screening of small molecule libraries
to find interesting phenotypes like protein degradation or other induced
proximities-driven approaches.
The corollary of that is in the small molecule space, you want to find molecules.
In the genetic mapping space, rather than running a single CRISPR screen to
identify the regulator of one protein, wouldn't it be powerful if we could run
screens of CRISPR screens to map an entire pathway or an entire family of proteins
that stabilize or destabilize?
And so this really begs the question, how can we observe changes in the proteome at
scale to drive molecule discovery and biological discovery?
And so I'll talk a little bit about the efforts towards how we can maybe build a
new way to think about trying to find new molecules that change protein
levels.
Okay, so
there's a large number of ways that you could profile protein stabilization
changes. We wanted to take a step back and ask if you could design from scratch an
assay that would allow you to profile proteins at scale with high
sensitivity, what would that look like? And so here's what we came up with.
One is that it would allow you to differentiate cell death and viability.
So having it in live cells is really advantageous because you can tell if something
is toxic or not.
You want to be able to detect realistic of degradations of a protein of interest.
So I think everyone's dream is from a screen finding a molecule that degrades your
protein 90+%. The reality of that is for challenging targets,
that's probably going to be pretty hard.
So you want to detect something that you can actually do med chem on.
And as a good starting point, you want to find those hits.
So I would say that trying to find degraders that operate within the 10% to 50%
window is actually the challenge.
You want your signal to be robust, right? So you want to minimize false positives.
And for us, this really means you want to create signal rather than destroy signal.
So you need to have this inversion, where if you're looking at protein
destabilization, you need to somehow convert that into increase of
something.
You want to be able to do this across many hundreds of proteins.
Maybe even many hundreds of proteins simultaneously.
And then finally, you want it to be relatively mechanistically agnostic.
You don't necessarily care about how your protein is being degraded sometimes, just
that it is being degraded and being degraded selectively.So
we put all these ideas together, and obviously you want to do this from many, many
molecules at once And we thought, well, how does
nature actually sense protein degradation in the first place?
So nature's developed transcription as a way to read out destabilization of
proteins Okay? So very famously, this molecular switch,
where upon some stimulus, IKB alpha is degraded and leads
to NF-kappa B initiating transcriptional responses, is a really powerful
example of that. And in the DNA damage space, we observe this
again, where upon DNA damage,
MDM2 can be degraded, releasing p53 to then turn on DNA damage
response pathways. And so nature uses transcription to read out
protein degradation.
Can we do that synthetically? Can we build transcriptional response systems that
allow us to profile, and profile very sensitively, protein degradation?
And so what we came up with is this idea of ratiometric transcriptional activation,
where you fuse your protein of interest to an inhibitor of a transcription factor,
and then you place that in cells with a transcription factor.
And upon degradation of that inhibitor, which is fused to your protein of interest,
you release that transcription factor to turn on any gene you program.
So you can create an amplified readout in live cells using
fluorescence, cell survival, or even RNA barcode production
to create something that is scalable, highly sensitive, and very multiplexable.
And so what this relies on is our ability to program cells.
It relies on our ability to encode in cells this inhibitor, a transcription
factor, and then to use molecules to read out
production of our signal of interest.
And so we built a few test cases,
and what we saw in this test case where we used FKBP-12, F36B
as a model protein using dTag molecules as a nice degrader control,
is that you can directly observe production of GFP as a function of protein
degradation.
This is a polyclonal cell line. So we encode all of these different components into
a cell, and it's somewhat random. Different copy numbers of the different
components create this polyclonal cell line.
But what you can see is something that is quite good.
You now have this inversion of response, where upon protein degradation, you see
increase of GFP.
Can we tune it?
We go in and we do single-cell sorting at different concentrations of our molecule
to identify cells that are more and less sensitive.
And what this allows us to do is basically to shift the EC50 profile of any clonal
cell line to be extremely sensitive or to be relatively insensitive, depending
on what level of degradation you want to detect.
So on one side, we can go all the way to 160 picomolar for one EC50
value, and then we shift that about two orders of magnitude to a higher EC50
value. And what these EC50 values translate to is how sensitive can you
detect protein degradation.
At EC50, 160 picomolar, we're detecting 10% protein
degradation. At EC50, 13 nanomolar, we're
detecting about 99.5% protein degradation. Okay?
And so we can tune and we can dial in exactly what our threshold is for
being able to identify a signal.
And we mechanistically characterize what are the features that drive our ability to
be sensitive? What is determinant in this system for a degree of
sensitivity? And it is the ratio between the inhibitor and the transcription
factor, exactly what you expect. Which is as that inhibitor to
transcription factor ratio narrows, you become much more sensitive.
And we've developed ways to now program that in very precisely into any cell type
of interest.
For a technology, I think, to be reasonable, it's got to be applicable to many
different types of degrader mechanisms.
And so we did a small little panel looking at various degraders and
their proteins. So we can sense traditional PROTACs.
We always fuse our proteins of interest to the FKBP-12 domain to have an
internal control every time, so we can engineer our cells using that
orthogonal reporter. We can detect PROTACs.
We can detect this somewhat bespoke polymerization degrader mechanism
that these BIA 3-802 molecules use to polymerize
BCL-6 and degrade it. We thought that that might be challenging given that we're
making a protein fusion, but indeed, we're able to sense it very robustly.
We can even sense degradation of membrane proteins. Okay?
And these are a challenging class of proteins to think about because they're
ultimately getting routed to lysosomes for degradation.
And so across different degradation modalities and mechanisms and
processes, we're able to be very sensitive to identify protein degradation.
Here's an example of what this looks like in what you would think about for a
high-throughput experiment. If you wanted to find a degrader of MYC in
high throughput, you might think, let's do a GFP fusion to
MYC and see if we can directly see it.
And what I'm showing is a comparison between using this inversion mechanism that
we've developed, ratiometric transcriptional activation, to turn on signal as a
function of degradation, compared to direct loss measurements.
And by flow cytometry, you can see there is a small peak shift when you detect
direct loss. This is 90% degradation, by the way,
but not something that I would hinge a med chem development campaign on.
On the bottom, you can see what it looks like by flow cytometry when you use this
inversion mechanism to sense degradation.
Same degree of degradation, about a 10,000-fold increase in signal as
a function of loss of protein.
But you're not going to really screen by flow cytometry.
You're going to screen by microscopy, potentially.
Here's what it looks like on a microscope.
On the top, you can see GFP-MYC, or you can't see GFP-MYC.
So even when it's not degraded, because of the sensitivity of these microscopy
experiments, you just can't detect these direct fluorescence at proteins that are
expressed at their endogenous levels.
But here's the type of signal you can see when you use inversion mechanism to
enhance that signal. So I think it has a lot of potential for thinking about what
you can find in high throughput.
Okay. So how does it compare to what the go-to might be right
now, which is HiBiT screening?
We did that experiment. We went into the open cell database, and we
directly generated endogenously tagged fusions of HiBiT to
proteins across three orders of magnitude.
We tagged low-expression proteins like ATM, which is about 10 nanomolar in cells,
all the way up to PARP1, which is about 10
micromolar.We endogenously tag with either
HiBit, GFP, or our transcriptional inhibitor.
And in the middle here is shown the results of the GFP.
So you can see this nice gradation across different concentration levels.
And when you look at comparing the measurements you can
make with HiBit compared to ratiometric transcriptional activation, on the bottom
left corner, you can sort of see what it looks like.
HiBit fails to detect PARP1 degradation until you reach about
75% with statistical significance. Okay?
PARP1 is expressed, it's in the top 10% abundant proteins in
HEK293T cells. All right? So there's a sensitivity problem.
Ratiometric transcriptional activation can sense anything starting at about
10% protein degradation. So we see a clear statistically significant ability
to discover molecules that are degrading proteins at this maybe realistic level.
We profiled that using high-throughput confocal screening
experiments, and we mapped the Z' prime scores for these
different methods, Z' prime being a measurement of what is an ideal
sensitivity detection threshold.
Z' primes of about 0.5 are considered good.
A Z' prime of 1 is
perfect, and no one ever gets there, but we're trying.
What you can see is that for HiBit-based screening, only by
microscopy is the PARP1 expression level something that we have statistical power
to really reasonably say a hit is a hit without extensive follow-up.
But for all protein levels expressed, we can use ratiometric transcriptional
activation to get statistical power over hit finding.
And so how do we think about doing this?
Well, what we'd like to do is do high-throughput discovery of small molecule
degraders, right? And so,
what's been really nice about the cereblon family of molecules is what's emerged is
this idea that they can be reprogrammed as molecular glues.
What the rules are for that reprogramming remain to be figured out, but they
can be reprogrammed. And so we got excited by this idea of let's pan
for degraders.
So, the first experiment, just to show that we could do screens in the first place,
was to take a bioactive molecule library of about 10,000 molecules and try to
profile for known activity against c-MYC.
A lot of those molecules have anti-c-MYC activity in various contexts, or have been
reported to have anti-c-MYC activity.
And so we set up an experiment where we multiplex
two proteins together, MYC and SHP2.
We can turn on any fluorescent protein we want, for example, so we can turn on
green and red and a third color if we want in a single
experiment. So we can profile multiplex cells all at once.
And what we found were these molecules, the FK506 family of
molecules, are indeed regulators of c-MYC abundance.
And this is an observation that had been painstakingly worked out over about 10
years of very careful biochemistry, and we were able to see this directly
with a single high-throughput experiment, which I think is very powerful.
And so where I think we could sit, potentially, is in this space of an assay that
is incredibly sensitive,
can be scaled across many proteins, and also can be scaled across many
libraries. And so what can we do with that?
Well, the first thing we did was we took an in-house library that the Gray lab had
nicely provided of about 1,000 molecules.
We built about 60 different cell lines
to screen against, and in 48 hours, we acquired all the data on this heat map.
And
while there might be, and there are many interesting stories here about
proteins and molecules that are maybe selective or not selective, or how do you
think about that, I would say this data is more powerful in aggregate.
And because this data being more powerful in aggregate is because maybe
if we get enough data, we can start to actually figure out the rules of
reprogramming for cereblon molecules.
And so rather than following up on any one of these, what we decided to do was
scale up. We got a library of about 10,000 cereblon-binding
molecules that have fragments basically appended to the other side.
And we built a library of about 120 protein targets.
So pick your favorite therapeutic target. It's probably in the protein library.
And we just looked at toxicity to start, right?
So in this 10,000-molecule library, what we saw was
about 2,000 molecules had some degree of toxicity.
What was interesting are the cases where there were protein-dependent toxicity
events. So even just by having the element of viability in our screen, we could
already start to figure out where there might be some interesting biological cases
and molecules to follow up on.
So we screened all those molecules. What did the degradation profiles look like?
So we screened 10,000 molecules by 120 proteins.
Again, many potentially exciting things to follow up on from this.
But again, I would say the data is more powerful in aggregate than it is for any
individual protein. Yes, we can find hits. Here's an example.
We found a nice hit for PDE6D.
Very good degradation. Because we screen both on and off targets, we get a very
good selectivity profile directly from this screen without having to do
comparative proteomics in any way.
We know basically what it's hitting and what it's not hitting directly from the
primary screen.
So we can find hits.
And so our library basically was built to have interesting targets, but
also have biased G-loop-containing proteins that Monterrosa
has theoretically surmised might potentially be degraded.
We put all that together, and the reason we put all that together is because we
want to figure out the rules for how to reprogram cereblon.
And we use that using phenotypic data that we're generating from a sensitive assay
that is scalable across both positive and negative data points.
So we take all that data, and we integrate it with a novel machine learning
algorithm that predicts the language of chemistry.
It's using an energy-rank alignment protocol to basically
tune and identify molecules based on the ChemBL database of things that
in theory have been made before. And using all that
information, it predicts the next molecule to make.
So we can generate a unified model across all 120 proteins that
predicts selectivity and potency.To a pretty reasonable degree.
And so I'm just showing some examples in the bottom left of molecules that were
predicted, and their Tanimoto similarity score is to sort of their nearest neighbor
in the library. One of the advantages of this algorithm that we use is
that we can tune how differentiated we want it to be from the molecules that it's
seen before. And so we can generate entirely new chemical space, or we can
try to find the nearest neighbor that maybe MedChem might not predict.
And so I would say that the rules to figure out this are really advantaged by
scaling across protein and molecule space at the same time with a data depth
that is sensitive.
But at some point, we're going to run into a time limitation of if we're
using microscopy-based screening, you can only have so many
colors at once, right? So we screen 10,000 molecules by 120 proteins.
In terms of total on-microscope time, it's a couple of weeks.
How do we think about scaling to even larger?
Larger numbers of molecules across maybe the entire human proteome.
We need to figure out a different way of reading out.
And so we did an experiment where we pooled five different cell lines, each of them
turning on GFP, and we tried to figure out what sort of sensitivity could we get
from a multiplex experiment through imaging.
And this is flow cytometry data, but the thing that I want you to look at is when
you treat these five proteins when pooled together with LC2, which is a degrader of
KRAS, you see a 1% change in fluorescent signal
between the bottom row and the second to bottom row.
No one's going to believe a 1% change. Okay, so how do we fix this?
We can fix this by rather than using a fluorophore as an output, we can use an
RNA barcode as the thing that we're reading out.
So the thing that gets turned on when a protein is degraded is production of a
unique barcode, allowing us to barcode many different cell lines
simultaneously and hopefully do proteomics by sequencing.
And here's an example of what that looks like.
So remember,
I showed that 1% change for KRAS degradation.
But when you use RNA barcode as the readout in the same multiplex experiment,
you now see a 15% amplification of that compared to the library.
And that is something that is real.
And we can do this for, in a single well, about 200 proteins at once.
So we can now use this idea of sequencing and
high-throughput sequencing rather than proteomics to read out sensitivity at scale.
Okay.
Induced proximity didn't start with degraders, I would argue.
It started with just bringing two proteins together.
And 30 years ago, we got excited by FK506.
We got excited by these molecules that just induced proteins to come
together. And we're still excited by that.
Revolution Medicines and Drugs are doing similar things with a new flavor.
I think the thing that's really exciting about the example I'm showing here is
this idea that you can accelerate the reactivity of an electrophilic warhead
by inducing this ternary complex to form.
You're essentially generating a catalyst, which is an exciting idea for the
molecular glue space.
But if you want to find these, you have to solve a problem.
You have to solve a protein by protein by molecule space screening problem.
And that's a big problem.
So can we build at least a strategy that allows us to be sensitive and
similarly access a scale that we can do with degraders now?
So to do that, we built a system where we take that same idea of
ratiometric transcriptional activation, we build in another layer, where now rather
than inducing degradation directly of our target, by inducing
interaction between two proteins, that leads to degradation of the transcriptional
inhibitor and turning on our signal.
So this degron-induced degradation is what drives this process.
We did some theoretical modeling just to figure out what would actually matter for
this. And what I'm showing here is that as the protein-protein interaction
strength weakens, you need a much stronger degron in order to
observe signal. And so really the reliance of this is that can you find a degron
that is sufficiently strong enough where you can observe weak protein-protein
interactions, the types of protein-protein interactions that you might discover
from a molecule screen.
So we encode all of these components in cells, we engineer them,
and here's an example of data where the system that we used was
abscisic acid and PYL1, a nice model system where the molecular glue abscisic acid
induces them to come together. And what you can see is that when we build the
system and we treat with abscisic acid, you see a really high degree of GFP
activation. So we can induce production of a fluorophore just by bringing these two
proteins together in a small molecule-induced fashion.
The nice part about this system is that we can make rational mutations to the
interface between these two proteins and tune their affinities, measure them by
BLI, and directly correlate sensitivity of the recombinant proteins to what we
can see in cells. And so what we observed by our transcriptional assay activation
is that the sensitivity limit is somewhere beyond double-digit
micromolar in terms of protein-protein interactions.
So we actually can't sense by BLI the weakest interaction, which
is about one millimolar detection limit, but we can access a
sensitivity of interaction here that I think is really exciting, that if there's an
interaction to be found, we can find it.
Here's another example.
We generated a cell line that senses interaction of FKBP12 and FRB
induced by rapamycin,
and the KD for this interaction is about 12 nanomolar.
But as you can see, our sensitivity detection starts at about
0.17 nanomolar. We're sensing this interaction two orders of magnitude
below the KD in cells. So it's incredibly sensitive to figure out and pick
out these interactions.
So what are we doing?
We're trying to solve the molecule by protein by protein problem.
What we've done is figured out a way to basically screen the entire human
Orpheome against a list of presenter proteins that you might care about,
and to do that across a molecule library.
And the reason we can do this is because using transcriptional activation as a way
to turn on any gene of interest, we can then isolate
cells in parallel from molecule libraries to hopefully
find these new examples of molecular glues for any two proteins.
So hopefully more to come on that soon.
Okay. And with that, I want to thank the people who did all the work.
So Melissa Gray is a fantastic postdoc.
She built this idea of ratiometric transcriptional activation for
high-throughput screening, both across molecule space and genetic
space.And Jen and Kara have really been taking that
into this new space of molecular glue discovery.
And then finally, Caitlin has been doing all of the screening for our
Cerablon-focused, and machine learning-driven molecular sort of discovery
campaigns. And with that, I'm very happy to take any questions.
Thank you.
Great assay, great data. Thank you very much.
Going back to your 10,000 molecule, 120
protein screening, you showed in the initial graph
with the cell viability that most of the proteins or
dependent proteins come in pairs, so it's two proteins.
I think that's easy to conceptualize because we would always
imagine two partners, right, in that interaction.
But there's also others where the dependencies were on more
proteins. What do you make of that?
Yeah. So that data was showing--
We screen two cell lines always simultaneously, and so we can't
differentiate if the molecule's toxic to one or the other.
So each of those is single protein, sort of single target protein-containing
lines. But because we look at them at the same time, we don't know,
actually,
so the toxicity that we're inducing, we don't know, basically.
So it's always like it's two, but it could be more than two.
And so when we say this molecule is toxic for nine
or greater than nine cell lines, it's because they were sort
of screened in pairs, basically. And so it's just a function of how we do the
measurement. It's not a function of saying, "When these three things are put
together, that makes it toxic," or, "When these four proteins are together, that
makes it toxic."
Oh, I see.
Do you have plans for
an assay where you actually put them together?
Oh, yeah. That's
fairly straightforward. We have developed ways to basically just engineer
multiple proteins all together. The problem is, if you want to differentiate which
one, you have to create orthogonals for each.
We figured out a way to put three different orthogonal circuits into the
same cell and be able to detect three proteins simultaneously in a cell.
It's just a little bit more arduous in engineering compared to the sort of pooled
screening.
Thank you.
Hi. Great talk. Yeah. We are developing
a similar strategy to do the
KL function.
Can you move the microphone?
Move the microphone down.
Yeah. To screen the
molecular glue to get the KL function.
I was wondering
how to
distinguish
the degrader or if the molecular glue
is a repressor, like
the transcription repressor. Yeah.
I see.
Yeah, so I don't think we've found a case yet where recruiting a
global transcriptional repressor actually shuts off the
activity entirely.
The actual transcriptional signal is pretty hyperactive, and so it would
take a really powerful interaction, I think, to shut it off.
In terms of differentiating between degradation-
Circle Pharma-
Okay.
In terms of differentiating degradation, there we
always have the controls baked in, so when we do these screens, we have the sort of
negative controls and the positives already sort of in there.
So we can know if it's an sort of induction of molecular
interaction or if it's just degradation.
Yeah. And the kind of platform for your
induced proximity to
get the KL
function to recruit another protein
to the transcription factor. You used the
overexpress system or the endogenous
system? Yeah.
Yeah. So we actually insert proteins using recombinases
directly at genetic loci that are most reasonably matched to their
transcriptional levels endogenously.
So we try to do things as close to near native as possible.
Okay. Can we discuss the detail later?
I have a similar platform.
Okay.
Thank you.
Cool. Thanks.
All right.
Great.
Well, thank you all for your attention.
We'll thank Will and
Steve and myself
one last time. Thanks.